let's talk about Shepard Smith's
reaction to the migrant Caravan troop
mobilization that Donald Trump is
starting with 5,200 troops and
potentially 14,000 troops by the time
that the caravan actually arrives in the
United States I've talked about Shep
Smith many times on the program he is
the lone voice of reason on Fox News
every once in a while Chris Wallace says
something that makes sense but Shep
Smith here once again straight up
destroying Trump on Fox News laying out
super clearly in a way that very few of
us would ever expect to hear on Fox News
that this is merely playing politics
check out Shep Smith listen to what he's
saying because he makes perfect sense
tomorrow the migrants according to Fox
News reporting are more than two months
away if any of them actually come here
but tomorrow is one week before the
midterm election which is what all of
this is about there is no invasion no
one's coming to get you there's nothing
at all to worry about when they did this
to us got us all riled up in April
remember the result was 14 arrests where
America we can handle it but like I said
a week to the election and Jennifer
Griffin's on it from the Pentagon
I love the hyper calm delivery from Shep
and ie I continue to just be curious
about how he's keeping his job on Fox
News the one lone voice of reason with
the exception of the occasional Chris
Wallace he's got to have very good
entertainment lawyers who have made a
contract that would make it very
difficult or expensive for Fox News to
break right the other possibility and I
I kind of keep going back to this I know
it's sort of cynical it's possible that
Fox sees Shep as a sort of set-piece
kind of controlled opposition a
counterbalance that Fox News can claim
to have to make them plausibly balanced
even though outside of Shepard Smith
they're effectively the right-wing
propaganda wing of the Trump
administration and I was think
yesterday when we were talking about
megyn kelly and I was reading about Shep
Smith NBC News made such an obvious
mistake bringing Megan Kelly who simply
doesn't fit at NBC News she's going to
now end up losing her daytime show her
appeal was clearly to the Fox News
audience Shep Smith would actually do
well on other channels if given more
opportunities to do high-profile
interviews and an opportunity to get
away from the toxic fox news audience
but maybe he just has a better deal at
Fox News I want to hear from you what do
you think makes it so that Shep is
allowed to do this at Fox News I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show and we'll
be back right after this today's program
is sponsored in part by Blink accom
slash Pakman if you've not already heard
about blinka it's amazing it's an app
for your phone tablet or web browser and
what they do is they take nonfiction
books popular nonfiction critically
acclaimed nonfiction they condense the
book into a fifteen minute audio book
you get all the most important
information and insights from each book
but you can soak up the entire essence
of the book in one sitting I've listened
to a ton of books on blinkin recent one
is a Robert Rice's new book the common
good also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudo-science
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a david pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube use
the link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n